Montezuma ran a vibrant empire from one of the world's largest cities with an
amazing headdress.
But unlike his mind,
neighbors,
he didn't leave us books and monuments full of sentences,
and yet we know the Aztecs called him.
Wait,
[inaudible] not emperor that he didn't call chocolate chocolate and that
Montezuma is not how he said his name.
No,
no,
that's not it either.
After college I went through linguistics withdrawal,
so I tore through any language you book.
I could,
including empires of the word right away,
there's this epic encounter between Spanish can,
keystone doors and the Aztec Emperor.
But if we see a people inevitably about to be wiped from history,
this book sought to high cultures meeting across the great divide,
each telling their own story in their own words.
I lowered the book,
their own words.
We know how Montezuma spoke.
It turns out we do partly because while some brought swords to the new world,
others reached for pens and informants.
They wrote histories and dictionaries and rough grammars with helpful tips about
Aztec.
Well,
the Mexican language.
Now what tips,
like when you see two consonants in a row,
pronounce both.
A house was cuddly,
not guy you like.
If this were Spanish tips,
like there are only four vowels,
a e Oh,
so if you spot an Ooh,
it's really just an Owen disguise.
The word for flour is [inaudible] valves can be long to Ah,
a e.
Oh,
a flower isn't just churches,
it's short cheat.
Spelling is clunky,
but it works.
If we see it as Spanish letters layered over simple Aztec sets,
SAS say,
see Soca Cozza say Si.
So linguists would have done a better job,
but bygones above all the old Grammer's show off the structure of not what nouns
attach.
Affixes Oh,
do they ever non [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Nancy ne verbs.
Use Incorporation,
jamming things we'd call different words into a single verby body.
Nicola [inaudible] meet [inaudible].
The grammar only gets more fun from there,
but there's a lot these premodern grammars don't tell us.
Take a concrete example and important one chocolate.
We suspect it must've come from,
she'll call lot bitter water,
but there's no trace of that in the early literature,
in classical times.
The base word for the bean and the drink was [inaudible] to sort out all these
missing words and sounds.
Let's look into Montezuma's future and his past Montezuma's,
Aztecs also had books are mostly,
I was always told I emotionally we're full of pictographs.
Not Real writing,
but experts or taking a second look spelled the word,
see what woman as you like.
Here's how one glyphs does with two bars.
The bars stand for the syllable Wa compare that to the way colonial writers
spelled the sound war.
I walk,
cut way Eggy and we'll see.
Wow.
So this isn't a val,
Ooh,
it's an h plus you representing the consonant.
Woo.
But our best evidence comes from modern mouths.
Yup.
People still speak.
Now what they may call it mass say wildly meaning commoner or even just Mexican,
but they help pin down it's sounds.
Those uhs do indeed correspond to was there really are just four vowels and this
fourth valgus freely between Owen.
Ooh.
Which explains those earlier spelling variations.
And elephant in the room or Jaguar in the temple,
but this TLL over the place is car.
You'll even hear two k sounds as in skull,
godly plus a tricky made by rounding your lips,
Cla Creek.
This sound can even end a syllable day.
The spelling here is awkward and inconsistent.
Today I'm going with this one,
tie all this pronunciation analysis together and we can dig up a glimpse of what
Montezuma's named sounded like in his day.
Motech Soma,
but out of respect,
you might want to add the polites suffix motech so Maxine,
did you hear that?
Seen not seen certain consonants were voiceless at the end of a syllable.
Try this one.
NOCCA cow with a voiced will in the middle and a voiceless w at the end,
ELLs are particularly noticeable.
They're not [inaudible] but as pet,
but there were still too many unknowns.
Remember your favorite sound?
We'll some speakers ditch it.
They say no what or now on who's right or take this h before consonant colonial
texts in precisely called it a salad.
PGO A skip.
Come on.
The IPA wasn't even invented yet.
Today.
Most people say Ms Chic,
a few same issue.
Which ones older?
Zoom out from now,
what to see its siblings,
cousins,
parents,
grandparents.
Carefully comparing them for patterns.
Linguist proved they're part of a Youdo as tech and family that stretches from
Central America up to the western US linguists,
including this guy wharf place.
Now within that history,
warf worked out that an early tea sound change into,
oh,
so now what is older?
Wait later linguist showed this change applied to the entire now one branch.
Now what?
And Noah were the innovations.
So keep practicing your,
that Pesky San Diego that sound you lop off words when you borrow them,
even if it's the Aztec name for themselves.
That was even more elusive,
but hard work showed a syllable final stop like a k or a t turning into a catch
in your throat before becoming the popular sound.
In the old days they said,
ms she cut slot,
totally plot.
Oh and they stressed the second to last syllable.
We got way you eat lots.
Swanee so Aztec had a family.
It also had neighbors,
unrelated mezo American neighbors that all shared the same features,
including a special ritual language as tech ritual.
Speech was unlike the Common Masay,
wildly speech elite schools,
cosmic huck taught noble children the old ways in where with laboratory.
So if you've been paying attention,
you know that church,
it means flower and quick.
That means song.
Well,
you still need ancient parallelisms to grasp the Nobel phrase [inaudible] in
Oak,
we call a stylish way to say my poem.
This is the same ritual language from my tale of the fall of the empire in
Matson in motor bed scene,
just to say your city,
he was at the crossroads of an ancient language when that wasn't just about
articulating.
Now what sounds are building intricate words,
but making your speech ring with poetry like a real emperor.
I mean,
wait,
Latwonda stick around and subscribe for language.